[MUSIC PLAYING]
MINGLIANG WEI: Good
morning and welcome.
My name is Ming.
I'm the tech lead for the
social platform at Niantic.
NINIANE WANG: Oh.
I'm Niniane.
I'm a senior director of
engineering at Niantic.
MINGLIANG WEI: We are very
excited today at San Francisco
to talk about our
story with Spanner,
how we migrated terabytes of
data from the existing database
system to Spanner while ensuring
performance, reliability,
and company-wide buy-in.
This is the overview
of the topics
that we will cover today.
NINIANE WANG: I will talk a
bit about Niantic as a company.
Our mission is five
words, "Adventures
on foot with others."
We make products that
encourage our users
to go outside, walk around,
and explore the real world
around them, and also to have
face-to-face, real-world social
interaction with other users.
Many years ago we started
making "Ingress," a game that
has many loyal users.
And then two years ago,
we launched "Pokemon GO."
And we have a very
anticipated game coming out,
which is "Harry Potter,
Wizards Unite," our newest
augmented reality
real-world game.
Ming will tell us a bit
about his background.
MINGLIANG WEI: Again, I
work in the social platform
team at Niantic.
My team takes care of login,
accounts, friendships,
and messaging.
Before this job,
I worked at Google
on quite few different things,
including API infrastructure,
Gmail, display ads,
and server performance.
NINIANE WANG: And I'm Niniane.
So Niantic was part of
Google for some years
and then was spun out
into its own company.
So we are now an
independent company that
used to be a part of Google.
So I'm a senior director
of engineering at Niantic.
I oversee the new Harry
Potter game, "Ingress,"
and then parts of our real-world
augmented reality developer
platform, including
the social piece--
for example, this powers
the "Pokemon GO" friendlist
and trading feature that came
out a couple of weeks ago.
Other pieces of the
platform include analytics,
sponsorships, events, and CRM.
Previously, I was
founder and CEO
of a startup, Evertoon, that was
acquired by Niantic last year.
I was CTO of Minted.
And I spent five
years at Google,
where I co-founded
Google Desktop Search,
was tech lead of Gmail ads
when Gmail came out in 2004.
I founded Google Lively,
an avatar chat product.
And before that, I was at
Microsoft for five years,
and I was an engineering lead
on "Microsoft Flight Simulator."
So some information about
the problems and challenges
that we face at Niantic.
In terms of data storage,
when we store information
using a geographic related index
and there are many players that
converge on one
real-world location,
this can create hotspots for our
reads and writes of that data.
We have periodic events where
up to hundreds of thousands
of users will go to one
location or play around
the world in community
events, and this
can cause spikes of activity
for our data storage
and other server systems.
During those times
and in general,
we have a high volume
of reads and writes.
And one extra challenge is that
unlike other products where
users are by themselves
and any lag between users
is not visible--
even a lag of minutes may
not be apparent to the user--
in our use case, many users
are playing next to each other
and are looking at
each other's phones.
So we need immediate
consistency,
because any lag of
updates between the phones
will be visible to the users.
This is an example of
our need for out data
storage and other systems to
perform well at high volume.
This graph is the Cloud
Datastore transactions
per second at the "Pokemon
GO" launch in 2016.
The orange line at the
bottom is the targeted,
the anticipated traffic.
The red line is five
times that, which
is the worst case or best case,
depending on your perspective.
And the green line is
what actually happened.
So we reached 50 times
of actual traffic,
and there was a need for the
data storage and other systems
to perform well at that scale.
Here is a diagram
of the architecture
of our real-world augmented
reality developer platform.
There are many different pieces
to it, many aspects to what
makes a real-world game
or application successful.
We won't go through
all the pieces here,
but the piece we will
be talking about today
is social, which is near
the middle of this diagram.
The point behind this
diagram is to indicate how
there are many different teams.
They each have their
own data storage needs.
So when we think about migrating
from Datastore to Spanner,
there's different
timelines of teams,
different APIs that they
have, and different priorities
of each team.
All Niantic games and apps
are powered by Google Cloud.
We started years ago with App
Engine and in recent years
have been using
Kubernetes Engine.
We use Bigtable and
Datastore, and we
are migrating from
Datastore to Spanner, which
is the content of this talk.
For our analytics, we use
BigQuery, which we populate
with Pub/Sub and Dataflow.
And in addition, we have
monitoring, logging,
and virtual private
cloud for these systems.
And now, Ming will go over
the technical challenge
in our approach for moving
from Datastore to Spanner.
MINGLIANG WEI: Thanks, Niniane.
So now, let's talk about
the database system
that we use to
store player state.
We started using Datastore
to store our player
state since 2012
when we launched
our first game, "Ingress."
It has served us really well.
In fact, we built our
second game, "Pokemon GO,"
and launched it in 2016
on top of Datastore.
Datastore is a
scalable NoSQL database
that supports transactions.
It is strongly consistent if
it's queried by primary key
or by ancestors.
However, the
secondary index, they
are not strongly consistent.
They are only
eventually consistent.
By that, we mean
newly-created rows may not
appear in the secondary
index immediately,
and rows that are
modified or deleted
may stay in the index for
a short period of time.
As you can imagine, this could
cause a problem to our players.
For example, in "Pokemon GO,"
we have this friendlist feature
where you can add a
player as your friend.
In order to do that, you need to
first create an InvitationCode,
and the other player
needs to use this code
to add you as a friend.
And this InvitationCode actually
goes to the secondary index
of the player table.
If the secondary
index is behind,
the other player wouldn't
be able to find you and use
the same InvitationCode
you just provided to him.
So the other player has to wait
until the secondary index is
populated.
So we have a lot of
experience on this.
And we created a
workaround, which
essentially is a new table that
functions as a secondary index.
In this case, the table is
the InvitationCode table,
and the primary key
is InvitationCode.
For Datastore, if you
query by primary key,
it's always strongly consistent.
This actually solves the
problem of secondary index
being behind.
However, it also
brings some problems,
because now we have the same
data in two separate tables.
Whenever a game entity is
updated, a lot of the times,
the secondary index table
has to be updated too.
We build a lot of
code just to make
sure the data in both
tables are consistent.
And this is an
error-prone process.
As you can imagine, as the
number of a secondary indexes
increase, the amount of code
to deal with this problem
is becoming unmanageable.
So we are searching the
next generation data
storage that can power our games
in the next five or 10 years.
The following criteria
are important.
Firstly, the cost.
It has to be as
good as Datastore.
In terms of latency, it must
be at least similar or better
than Datastore.
The ability to perform
relational queries
is important too,
because with that,
we can just use a single
query to do most things.
Here is where Spanner
comes into the picture.
Spanner is a new database
system that's offered by Google.
It gets into GA
status back in 2017,
and we keep a close eye on
this new database system.
Compared with Datastore,
Spanner is also very scalable,
and it's a SQL database,
which means it allows
us to do aggregation joins.
The secondary indexes in
Spanner are strongly consistent.
Other things we really
liked about Spanner
include a unique index and
the cascading deletion.
Within the organization,
we had a lot
of discussion about, what do
we do with this new storage
system?
Do we want to try
it and possibly
use it to power all of our
products in the next five
or 10 years?
If yes, when do we start?
How should we start it?
The points from people
that are in doubt
includes the following.
Datastore works just fine
for the current games.
Why are we spending so
scarce engineering resources
to replace something
that is not broken?
The organization has so
many tools and knowledge
built around Datastore.
We have zero on Spanner.
Do we want to go through the
same process of learning again?
Using a new database
system actually introduces
a risk to new product launches,
because we have very little
knowledge on the system.
If we ever want to migrate
the data from the existing
system to Spanner, it will be
a pretty complex engineering
process, and there is a
risk associated with that.
We also heard the following
from people who are supportive.
Working around the secondary
index being stale problem
is just becoming so difficult.
The number of secondary indexes
are becoming more and more.
And the amount of code that
just to deal with this problem
becoming unmanageable.
This is the one opportunity
we can advance our database
system, our database
technology, to make
our system a lot simpler.
We heard Spanner
has a great latency.
I think we should just try it.
As a data scientist,
I am so excited to be
able to use SQL query to get
player intels from Spanner,
which otherwise, I
have to ask engineers
to write dataflow to get those
information from Datastore.
This is a new Google product.
We are going to get a lot
of help from Google side.
A note on the data migration--
so if we ever want to
decide to migrate existing
data to Spanner, we are talking
about moving terabytes of data
while they are being
changed by active players
at the same time.
This is, again, a very complex
engineering process, because we
need to make sure all of
the data between Datastore
and Spanner are in sync.
And we can't afford
any downtime.
After a lot of discussion
about tradeoffs and risks,
we have decided to start with
a low-QPS system to experiment
with Spanner.
It is a lot easier
to get agreement
for one experiment
with rollback options
than committing to a
long-term migration strategy.
The system that we chose
was the account system.
The account system
is relatively simple.
It has a lower
QPS than the game.
And most of the
queries are read-only.
We have this upcoming feature
called account linking, which
allows the player to log in
with both Google and Facebook
credentials.
If we could build this
on top of Spanner,
we can do it quickly,
because we no longer
need to write code to deal
with the secondary index
being stale problem.
There's also risks.
The account system is one
of the most critical systems
that we have.
If the account system
is not working,
nobody can play our games.
Relying on data
migration for Spanner
also may delay the launch
of account linking.
The account system manages all
of the codenames and logins
for all of our games.
It also helps to locate
players for admin tools.
It is constantly
running on App Engine.
And before the migration,
the storage is Datastore.
We are going to
move it to Spanner.
Now is the data
migration process.
It is roughly divided
into three steps.
The first step is
copying the data,
which means copying
all of the accounts
from Datastore to Spanner.
The second step is validation.
In this step, we validate data
between the two repositories
and make sure they
are actually in sync.
The third step is switching
Spanner and making
it the source of truth.
All of the data we return to
the player will be from Spanner.
Step one, copying the data.
During this step, we are
copying terabytes of data
at the same time they are being
modified by active players.
So the first thing
we need to do is
whatever change is made
by the active players,
we want the change to
be populated to Spanner.
To achieve this, we
used dual writes.
We created a
transaction listener
in the data access
layer of Datastore
so that whenever account
changes by an active player,
we copy the whole
account to Spanner.
So this takes care of the
changes made by active players.
What about the inactive players?
We run a dataflow to copy
all accounts from Dataflow
to Spanner.
Wait, are there any
race conditions?
Yes, because the
same data in Spanner
could be modified
by both transaction
listener and the dataflow
at the same time.
So there could be
race conditions.
To resolve this, we
carefully wrote the dataflow
to use an insert mutation.
Insert mutation fails
if the account already
exists on Spanner.
This situation happens when
the active player has already
made changes to the account,
and therefore, the account
is copied by the transaction
listener to Spanner.
So during this process, we
continue monitor Spanner
latency and throughput
to make sure Spanner
is working fine with the
traffic from the dataflow.
By the way, the dual writes
can be turned off if needed.
Step two is data validation.
This step lasted for two weeks.
During this two weeks, we ran
validation multiple times.
The validation is
done by Dataflow.
The Dataflow reads
accounts, all accounts
from Datastore and Spanner
and then compares them.
We do expect some
inconsistent results.
The reason for that is just
because the accounts reading
from Datastore and Spanner may
come from different timestamps.
For these inconsistent
results, we
will sample them and
manually check them to make
sure they are actually in sync.
At the end of the
second week, we
are very confident that the
data between two repositories
are in sync.
Now, we are ready to switch
Spanner as the source of truth.
We still keep
writing to Datastore,
because we want the option
to roll back to Datastore
if anything goes wrong.
We keep writing to Datastore
for another two weeks.
During this two weeks,
we keep monitoring
Spanner bug reports,
stackdriver counters,
[INAUDIBLE],, whatever
source we can
find if there's any issue
with the new system running
on Spanner.
And the whole migration
process from the beginning
to the end of step three
lasted for four weeks.
At the end of the
fourth week, we
are very confident that the
new system works properly
on Spanner.
Now we can turn off the
writes to Datastore.
With that, we can
no longer go back
to Datastore easily,
because the changes are not
populated there anymore.
Thanks to Google,
we got a lot of help
from Google Cloud support
team during the migration.
Particularly, we
received guidance
on performance regarding schema
design, indexing, and query.
We got early access to the
open source Spanner backup
tool, which allows us to
have peace of mind knowing
that if anything goes wrong, we
can still go back to an older
version of the data.
Google Cloud support team also
monitored our Spanner instance
during the migration to
make sure the instance is
performant, is working properly.
So this is four weeks of
hard work to copy the data
and validate it.
This is the result. We
are very happy to see we
have a lot better performance.
In terms of latency, it's
25% better at 50 percentile.
And we are very excited to see
there's a cost savings as well.
The reason behind
that is for Datastore,
it is charged by
number of accesses.
However, for Spanner, it's
charged by number of nodes.
After this data migration,
the whole company just
has a lot more confidence
on the new database system,
and we are ready to move
more systems to Spanner.
On top of Spanner, we launched
account linking in March
and friendlist in June.
In particular, for
the friendlist launch,
we modified our data access
layer to work with Spanner.
This allows us to move
existing systems to Spanner,
switching the data storage
layer from Datastore
to Spanner with just
changing a few lines of code.
Here's the QPS to Spanner.
The red line is
from account system,
and the blue line is from
the friendlist system.
The social platform team
launched account system
on top of Spanner to show how
to migrate data from existing
system to Spanner.
And we launched the friendlist
system on top of Spanner
to show that Spanner is
performant and scalable
to support live game
traffic from "Pokemon GO."
After the two
experiments on Spanner,
the whole company
is very excited.
A lot of teams decided to
move their product to Spanner
on their own.
We now have one
team in the process
of moving their product,
and another team
is in the planning stage.
So we found that instead
of continued debate,
the best way to convince is
start with a small experiment
and expand from there.
Here are the takeaways
from this talk.
For data migration, we
recommend the following steps.
Start with copying
and dual writes.
Do the write validation.
Switch the application
to the new storage.
And finally, turn
off original writes.
Always have a backup plan--
a rollback plan.
With that, we can always
go back to the state
before the migration
if anything goes wrong.
The one way to convince
the organization
to do an experiment is we
start from a low-traffic system
and expand from there.
[MUSIC PLAYING]